I heard that NASA has recently shut down
an ion engine
can you explain what this ion engine is
and does and potential and the potential
benefit yeah so and I am drive is what
we think of them as you know the big
challenge here is chemical rockets are
just so they this so yesterday yeah
there's so nineteen there's so Robert
gosh somebody could build it in a farm
and make a movie about it it's that easy
and that dull and old and the problem is
not that there was anything wrong with
with chemical rockets when they were
invented yeah it's just that a hundred
years later you think we'd be doing a
little better now yeah right and we're
not have something more modern more
efficient than a chemical recognizing
chemical rocket is all the Rockets
you've ever seen yeah all of them are
chemical rock these chemistry the energy
contained in in molecules sounds like
something that Thomas Edison would have
known how far we come from that guy that
dollars so you have this these atoms and
they come together as a molecule and
there is energy to be released if you
break apart the molecule that's how all
this works
that's how gunpowder works that's how
nitroglycerin works that's how the
rocket engines of the shuttle works so
it's all chemical energy being released
giving you propulsion ion drives are
much more efficient so the what we call
the impulse that the little push the
nudge that the rocket fuel gives you is
much higher compared with the mass of
fuel you ejected mm-hm
all right look at the shuttle rockets
and the poem that comes out when this
thing launches the mass of that fuel is
huge it is most of the mass of the
shuttle apparatus it is a new mule is
fuel so what's this so what is an ion
engine though so am i is it and iron
engine you what happens is you have a
gas and you ionize it so you strip
electrons off of it you need an energy
source to do that okay and then you set
up the device you set up a device that
ejects these little particles out the
back of the ship whatever this the
opposite direction you want to travel
and so what this what's called a
specific impulse the impulse from that
one
little particle that comes out and the
recoil of your ship is very high
compared with the mass that came out
very so very efficient so when you strip
electrons that creates way more energy
and disturb you literally then eject
them out what you can do with magnetic
fields and this is the other thing and
the response to your path is is awesome
that the problem is it's not very large
it's efficient but it's not very large
so you can only redirect spacecraft very
slowly
could you make a gun with it can you
make an ion gun that shot when we come
back we'll find out if you can make my
own you build this guns star talk radio
cosmic queries edition we'll be right
back so we were talking about an ion
engine but that made me go can you make
an eye on guns yeah you know with the
questioner asked an honest simple
innocent question about propulsion
through the universe you have to take
the idea make a gun out of it would it
be better if I said anion sword sounds
less reasonable
I said principle I suppose you can make
it oh he'll be a plasma gun this what is
you send plasma out at somebody that
sounds great it's like a great plan but
if the plasma is hot enough you can
vaporize their clothing and then there's
skin yeah in principle yeah make it
sound so evil and this will be like on
the list of the you know protected by
the Second Amendment yes will be yes
exactly
they never envisioned the ion plasma gun
that so many problems with having
poppers
yeah well constitutionally protect your
right to arm yourself with a plasma gun